And people were scared.
They were scared of population growth
and what they called "the population bomb" in 1968.
But then, if you look at the end of the graph,
the growth began to slow.
The decade --
the '70s, the '80s, the '90s, the noughties,
and in this decade, even faster --
our population growth is slowing.
Our planet is stabilizing.
We are heading towards nine, 10, or 11 billion people
by the end of the century.
Within that change, you can see tumult.
You can see the Second World War.
You can see the pandemic in 1918 from influenza.
You can see the great Chinese famine.
These are the events we tend to concentrate on.
We tend to concentrate on the terrible events in the news.
We don't tend to concentrate on the gradual change
and the good news stories.
We worry about people.
We worry about how many people there are.
We worry about how you can get away from people.
But this is the map of the world changed again to make area large,
the further away people are from each area.
So if you want to know where to go to get away from everybody,
here's the best places to go.
And every year, these areas get bigger,
because every year, we are coming off the land globally.
We are moving into the cities.
We are packing in more densely.
There are wolves again in Europe,
and the wolves are moving west across the continent.
Our world is changing.
You have worries.
This is a map showing where the water falls on our planet.
We now know that.
And you can look at where Çatalhöyük was,
where three continents meet, Africa, Asia, and Europe,
and you can see there are a large number of people living there
in areas with very little water.
And you can see areas in which there is a great deal of rainfall as well.
And we can get a bit more sophisticated.
Instead of making the map be shaped by people,
we can shape the map by water,
and then we can change it every month
to show the amount of water
falling on every small part of the globe.
And you see the monsoons moving around the planet,
and the planet almost appears to have a heartbeat.
And all of this only became possible
within my lifetime
to see this is where we are living.
We have enough water.
This is a map of where we grow our food in the world.
This is the areas that we will rely on most for rice and maize and corn.
People worry that there won't be enough food, but we know,
if we just ate less meat and fed less of the crops to animals,
there is enough food for everybody
as long as we think of ourselves as one group of people.
And we also know
about what we do
so terribly badly nowadays.
You will have seen this map of the world before.
This is the map
produced by taking satellite images,
if you remember those satellites around the planet
in the very first slide I showed,
and producing an image of what the Earth looks like at night.
When you normally see that map,
on a normal map, the kind of map that most of you will be used to,
you think you are seeing a map of where people live.
Where the lights are shining up is where people live.
But here, on this image of the world,
remember we've stretched the map again.
Everywhere has the same density of people on this map.
If an area doesn't have people,
we've shrunk it away
to make it disappear.
So we're showing everybody
with equal prominence.
Now, the lights no longer show you where people are,
because people are everywhere.
Now the lights on the map,
the lights in London, the lights in Cairo, the lights in Tokyo,
the lights on the Eastern Seaboard of the United States,
the lights show you where people live
who are so profligate with energy
that they can afford
to spend money
powering lights to shine up into the sky,
so satellites can draw an image like this.
And the areas that are dark on the map
are either areas where people do not have access to that much energy,
or areas where people do,
but they have learned to stop shining the light up into the sky.
And if I could show you this map animated over time,
you would see that Tokyo has actually become darker,
because ever since the tsunami in Japan,
Japan has had to rely on a quarter less electricity
because it turned the nuclear power stations off.
And the world didn't end.
You just shone less light
up into the sky.
There are a huge number
of good news stories in the world.
Infant mortality is falling
and has been falling at an incredible rate.
A few years ago,
the number of babies dying in their first year of life in the world
fell by five percent in just one year.
More children are going to school
and learning to read and write
and getting connected to the Internet
and going on to go to university
than ever before at an incredible rate,
and the highest number of young people going to university in the world
are women, not men.
I can give you good news story after good news story
about what is getting better in the planet,
but we tend to concentrate
on the bad news that is immediate.
Rebecca Solnit, I think, put it brilliantly,
when she explained: "The accretion of incremental, imperceptible changes
which can constitute progress and which render our era
dramatically different from the past" --
the past was much more stable --
"a contrast obscured by the undramatic nature of gradual transformation,
punctuated by occasional tumult."
Occasionally, terrible things happen.
You are shown those terrible things
on the news every night of the week.
You are not told about the population slowing down.
You are not told about the world becoming more connected.
You are not told about the incredible improvements in understanding.
You are not told about how we are learning to begin
to waste less and consume less.
This is my last map.
On this map, we have taken the seas
and the oceans out.
Now you are just looking
at about 7.4 billion people
with the map drawn in proportion to those people.
You're looking at over a billion in China,
and you can see the largest city in the world in China,
but you do not know its name.
You can see that India
is in the center of this world.
You can see that Europe is on the edge.
And we in Exeter today
are on the far edge of the planet.
We are on a tiny scrap of rock
off Europe
which contains less than one percent
of the world's adults,
and less than half a percent
of the world's children.
We are living in a stabilizing world, an urbanizing world,
an aging world,
a connecting world.
There are many, many things to be frightened about,
but there is no need for us to fear each other as much as we do,
and we need to see that we are now living in a new world.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)